ça va venir toucher à votre créativité
parce que tellement vous consommez
beaucoup de contenu comme vous n'êtes
plus productifs vous avez tous vu et le
taux de productivité
tout simplement parce que tu as ton
téléphone entre les mains tu ne peux
rien faire je ne peux rien faire parce
que la productivité est en baisse
constante
donc j'ai décidé de laisser de côté mon
téléphone pendant quelques heures est
occupé à faire autre chose comme la
cuisine mais en cuisine il fallait que
je filme pour des abonnés il fallait que
je fasse je crée du contenu
donc j'ai quand même essayé de d'avoir
des moments de cuisine loin de mon
téléphone parce que pendant le coville
n'y avait pas un grand chose à faire
faire de la lecture ce que je fais tout
le temps mais actuellement je le fais
sur mon téléphone j'écoute les livres
audio parce que j'ai pas temps de
prendre un livre ce qui est dommage
parce que je sais que je peux consacrer
quand même du temps pour la lecture le
sport bon quand on fait du sport bien
sûr on va pas voir se fonde sur soi pour
écouter de la musique c'est pas grave
donc il ya des activités qui me
permettent d'avoir les mains occupées et
qui nécessite de la concentration comme
le sport comme je viens de dire donc je
suis ensuite passé à l'étape suivante
qui est de faire une pause de 24 heures
ne rien posté sur mes réseaux et ne pas
consulter les notifications ce qui peut
être difficile pour les gens qui
attendent des messages de gens et qui en
cette addiction comme moi et je pense
que beaucoup de personnes en une chose
donc je le fais généralement le dimanche
puisque c'est plus simple quand il
s'agit de consulter les emails parce que
y'a pas un collaborateur qui va
t'envoyer un email dimanche mais ça peut
arriver après je laisse le dimanche pour
moi pour sortir pour passer des moments
de famille et je réponds à mes
partenaires en semaine ce qui est très
logique le lundi donc l'expérience de
pause me redonne la motivation et me
rend les idées plus claires à chaque
fois c'est magique mais à chaque fois
que je m'éloigne de mon téléphone je me
sens libre est beaucoup plus efficace
parce que parfois j'ai l'impression que
si je consomme beaucoup de contenu ça va
me permettre
d'acquérir plus de créativité mais en
fin de compte tellement je consomme du
contenu que j'ai l'impression que j'ai
tout vu et que je ne peux plus rien
faire alors il ya un livre que je vous
recommande vivement de cas de newport
qui s'intitule réussir sa vie grâce au
minimalisme digital moi je crois très
fortement en le minimalisme ça m'a
beaucoup aidé pour faire la détox que ce
soit dans ma vie que ce soit chez moi
que ce soit et ça c'est un autre sujet
si vous voulez on peut en parler une
prochaine fois
donc le livre est très qui le
minimalisme digital et le minimalisme
digital c'est c'est tout cet
encombrement numérique qui qui s'acharne
sur nous et qui nous déstabilise et à
chaque fois on reçoit une nouvelle
notification
comment on va se marier avec le
smartphone ou l'ordinateur
donc sachez qu'on a tous des mentalités
différentes et j'y crois fortement on a
tous des visions divergentes et des
occupations et des centres d'intérêts
différents
on veut tous réussir dans la vie comme
notre idole comme notre cio prix
préférait d'ailleurs les idoles et les
sirops ne sont pas connectés h 24 sur
leur téléphone malheureusement et en
veut s'inspirer d'eux
sauf que eux ils ne font pas donc pour
générer de l'argent ou développer son
business oui c'est bien d'être connecté
d'avoir une idée sur ce qui se passe
dans le monde mais il faut pas être trop
dedans donc j'espère que c'est clair
alors pour ne pas oublier les paons que
je vous les citer parce que c'est
important de rester organisés donc oui
exactement c'est pas possible de rester
collés devant son écran h24 ce que je ne
réussis pas à faire actuellement
sauf quand je me décide de faire la
détox c'est à dire aujourd'hui c'est bon
je vais pas vous cacher mon téléphone je
le laisse chez moi et je sors si c'est
pour des appels gens je prends le petit
téléphone
et voilà où il n'y a pas d'application
ou ziani et facebook
g juste les appels urgents donc je reste
collé à mon téléphone pour mon pc bien
sûr même si j'ai du boulot sur le pc je
vais sur le google sur youtube pour voir
des vidéos est restée pendant des heures
collé devant des compilations des vidéos
donc décidé de suivre parfois des
événements des bagarres virtuelle des
futilités et ça ça dépend énormément de
mon temps et je sais que moi je parle de
moi même et je sais que c'est le cas de
beaucoup de personne sauf que je ne veux
pas parler à votre place je sais que la
majorité de personne sauf de ça et moi
je me dis que je suis quand même
chanceuse parce que au lieu de juste
consommer le contenu sur internet
j'essaye d'être créatrice de contenus
pour pouvoir gagner quelque chose de ce
pan que je passe sur les réseaux
donc vous savez très bien que c'est très
simple c'est très facile à rien de plus
facile que de passer sept heures sur
youtube à regarder des vidéos sur
instagram facebook et que c'est très
très difficile de passer une heure en
train de bosser ou d'écrire un article
que vous devez vraiment écrire donc
c'est normal parce que le cerveau il
choisit la facilité c'est normal c'est
la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs on
choisit des contenus très simple pas du
tout difficile à consommer mais quand on
redevient conscients de notre situation
actuelle en se plaint du manque de temps
alors on reprend le contrôle de nos vies
à travers cette démarche intelligente
qui le fait de faire une détox
c'est à dire une fois tu te sens trop
dedans il faut en sortir en faisant une
petite baie tox pour ne pas trop être
plancher surélevé
il faut savoir que l'addiction à l'écran
sa cause le manque de concentration
surtout pour les gens qui ont un travail
qui nécessite énormément de
concentration et le fait de rester figé
sur son écran tu vas perdre la
concentration et c'est quelque chose
dans la majorité des jeunes en centre
c'est le manque de concentration et
c'est pas facile de récupérer cet homme
c'est un tout
puisqu'à chaque petite seconde de vide
on prend le téléphone c'est à dire juste
j'ai pas compris un mot j'ai pas compris
quelque chose sur mon pc et je vais voir
mon téléphone et ça fait la duchesse le
fit d'instagram facebook bon j'ai pas
facebook
heureusement sinon j'aurais passé 20
heures seront bénévoles alors jusqu'à ce
moment là il faut essayer de revenir sur
terre et reprendre le travail à chaque
fois que tu sens que tu est envahie par
les notifications
il ya des personnes qui rencontrent des
troubles de l'estimé de soi et je reçois
énormément de messages de la part de
personnes qui me disent josy je me
compare trop aux autres il avoue je me
compare trop aux autres tellement je
suis sur mon téléphone et je ne
comprenais pas ça pourquoi se comparer
aux autres il faut tracer sa vie et se
lancer ses propres sa propre son propre
référentiel
mais après je les ai compris
tellement je consommais énormément de
contenu que je commençais à me comparez
pas pour me comparer avec le physique
des autres mais je comparais le niveau
de mon travail au niveau des autres je
me disais ah il a réussi à faire ça moi
je n'ai pas encore fait c'est pas de la
jalousie c'est juste le fait de voir que
les gens les autres font des choses et
que moi je ne les fait pas alors que si
je si j'y pense vraiment je me rends
compte que confiante quand moi aussi je
fais des efforts moi aussi j'avance mais
à force de voir les autres j'ai
l'impression que les autres sont
meilleurs que il me dépasse
ce qui est très malsain comme comme
façon de voir les choses
et d'ailleurs on n'a aucune idée de la
réalité des autres
à part les quelques secondes qu'il nous
offre des photos retouchées qu'il ne
reflète pas du tout la réalité
après il ya des réalités qui sont
retouchées d'autres qui ne le sent pas
mais on peut pas juger la réalité des
autres sur 15 secondes de leur vie ou
juste je sais pas une quinzaine de
minutes sur
rideaux stores et donc tout d'abord je
vous conseille vivement de penser au
minimalisme digital je vais je reviens à
chaque fois j'en parle à chaque fois
parce que c'est une étape de faire le
tri par exemple moi sûrement pc il n'y a
pas beaucoup de il n'y a pas beaucoup de
fenêtres
il n'y a pas beaucoup de photos je
supprime tout ce qui est inutile et ça
m'aide énormément pour ne pas plonger
dans des histoires encore plus profonde
que youtube et et instagram
donc ça me permet de gagner plus d
espace pour le stockage ce qui est bien
et en même temps ça me permet de ne pas
être distrait par toutes les
modifications des autres applications
inutiles par ailleurs actuellement gêné
notification de d'applications qui vient
se rajouter à mon ordinateur et qui ne
servent à rien et les notifications ne
font perdre du temps quand même
donc il ya beaucoup de personnes qui ont
des applications qui n'ont quittant
jamais été utilisé et je vois ça sur les
téléphones de mai a mis beaucoup
d'application
après moi je garde pour des raisons de
stockage ne garde que les applications
qui me servent comme l'application de
transport la banque
instagram liesi mail et l'application
des photos les retouches dans tout ce
que j'utilise au quotidien le reste soit
je désactive des notifications soit je
le tue prennent ce qui est ce qui m'aide
un peu alors et pour ne pas être
désordonné en même temps c'est c'est
comme ta petite maison parce que tant
téléphone tuées portant sur ton
téléphone
c'est la petite maison s'est entiché toi
donc il faut quand même l'organiser
aussi et ne pas être distrait alors tant
que créatrice des comptes ne je ne peux
pas supprimer les réseaux sociaux comme
forme s'appelle personne il décide de
supprimer les réseaux sociaux et laisser
de côté moi je ne peux pas faire ça
malheureusement
ce qui est bien mais j'ai des
engagements à respecter est aussi une
présence permanente
pour élargir ma communauté et toucher un
grand nombre de personnes et c'est un
travail au quotidien
c'est un travail énorme même s'il ya des
personnes qui n'arrivent toujours pas à
voir à quel point c'est ça prend
beaucoup de temps mais ça va venir
il y aura quand même des personnages que
le temps qu'ils comprendront que c'est
un full time job le fait de vouloir
toucher beaucoup plus de personnes etc
et ce n'est pas du tout facile donc là
le partage et la création de fatick
oui mais j'aime beaucoup ce que je fais
donc je ne sens pas que c'est un travail
qui s'acharne sur moi mais c'est plutôt
le fait de se coller sur le fil
d'actualité sont raison c'est ce qui
m'énerve
bon je vais pas utiliser ce terme mais
ça m'énerve vraiment parfois quand je me
retrouve pendant une heure sur mon
téléphone sans avoir rien fait sans
avoir rien appris sans avoir rien gagné
et ça ça me
ça ne reste parfois donc oui c'est bien
de s'inspirer et d'apprendre de
nouvelles choses grâce aux autres mais
le problème c'est qu'en bien de temps
nous prenons pour glander sur les
réseaux sociaux devant l'écran et ça
affaiblit l'activité du cerveau ça te
rend pas du tout créatif pas du tout
productif et à la fin de journée ça te
rend un peu anxieux j'avoue
personnellement quand je ressens que je
n'ai pas fait grand chose ça me rend
triste j'aime pas ça que j'aime pas du
pas être productive et j'aime pas je
ressens une culpabilité quand je fais
pas beaucoup d'efforts alors je vous
conseille je sais pas s'il ya des
personnes qui ne savent pas mais vous
pouvez aller sur activité mais sur
paramètres de votre programme
ensuite vous allez sur mon activité
ensuite vous cliquez sur le temps
d'écran et ensuite vous cliquez sur
définir un rappel quotidien pour fixer
une durée alors avant j'avais fait une
durée de 30 minutes et à chaque fois je
veux dépasser les 30 minutes
l'application de m'envoyer une
notification pour sortir de là sauf que
je la désactiver à chaque fois parce que
30 minutes ce n'était pas suffisant
une heure ce n'était pas suffisant deux
heures ce n'était pas suffisant donc je
n'ai désactiver malheureusement donc
j'essaie de
me contrôler par moi même mais si vous
vous êtes engagés envers votre une
communauté ou vers des partenaires ou
des collaborateurs vous pouvez quand
même fixé cette 1h 2h 30 minutes comme
vous voulez comme ça vous avez au moins
se rappelle et tu peux également faire
ça sur les paramètres de ton téléphone
et je pense qu'il ya des éléments sur
mon téléphone hier à cette possibilité
de diminuer le temps d'écran au moins
lui rappelle va venir te faire ce type
dans la tête c'est à dire ah non je dois
arrêter après parfois en je décide de
laisser le creux et ça alors essayé
ensuite de faire une pause d'une demi
journée pour les gens qui n'arrive pas
du tout à faire 24 heures sans les liens
sociaux
elle y met quand même j'essaye de faire
une demi journée ou bien 4 heures 5
heures sans le téléphone ça fait
tellement de bien et pour donner du
temps à ma famille à mes proches à moi
même parce que ça fait tellement de bien
de se retrouver avec soi même de
d'écouter de la musique sans pour autant
avoir à être envahie et part je sais pas
un milliard de d'information par seconde
et le sang fait de se reconnecter avec
le monde réel
c'est un remède immédiat parce que quand
je me sens anxieuse et que j'arrête que
le téléphone j'ai l'impression que je
suis guéri
de quoi je sais pas mais je pense que là
une tonne d'informations et de données
par je ne sais pas en chaque minute
c'est énorme donc ça peut sembler
difficile au début pour les gens qui
sans vraiment addict mais par la suite
vous allez comprendre que c'est pas la
fin du monde que c'est possible que
c'est le fait de ne pas tchéquie ses
messages on va pas mourir de sa red bull
l'a alors maintenant ce qui est
important et c'est de penser au retour
aux réseaux sociaux c'est à dire je me
suis arrêté
je ne suis pas connecté pendant 24
heures j'ai essayé d une détox la pause
j'ai vraiment siby tous les cancers
je n'ai pas été envoyé par un mineur de
notification mais il faut très bien
filtrer les gens que tu suis au
quotidien parce que les gens que je suis
s'il ne t'apporte pas vraiment grand
chose tu n'as pas à les suivre
on va pas mettre de côté les personnes
et dire que là il faut choisir ce que tu
veux dans la vie et les gens qui te font
du bien parce que je vais pas dire qu'il
faut suivre des cartes constructibles
parce que moi sur les réseaux sociaux je
n'aime pas suivre énormément de comptes
constructif tout ce qui est information
ce qui est très utile oui j'aime bien
voir ça de temps en temps mais j'aime
bien passer du bon moment sur les
réseaux parce que j'ai l'impression que
c'est un moment de détente
donc je vais suivre des comédiens je
vais suivre des personnes qui me motive
je vais suivre des personnes qui donnent
des conseils kim wan intéresse
sauf que il faut quand même faire le tri
ne pas suivre et énormément de personnes
parce qu' énormément de personnes chacun
chacun a sa vision chacun à sa manière
de voir les choses
je peux pas suivre tout le monde et je
peux pas je peux pas consommer tout
toutes les données des personnes donc il
faut quand même filtré il faut quand
même garder un le strict minimum pour ne
pas se perdre et parce qu'il ya quand
même certaines personnes qui n'ajoute
aucune valeur ajoutée à mon
développement personnel et ça ça varie
d'une personne à une autre c'est pas on
va pas juger ne rajoute rien à ma valeur
à nous ils sont pas bien dans ces jeux
c'est pas pour catégoriser les gens
c'est juste qu'il faut voir ce qui me
conseille ce qui me concerne ce qui va
faire que mon développement personnel
mon développement
un mot propre échelle soit bien donc il
faut savoir que nos choix rapides
peuvent avoir des conséquences sur le
long terme de notre quotidien
alors décidé droits des citoyens sur ce
que tu veux et l'entourage que tu te
crées quand je suis aidé personne
motivée et ambitieuse
sache que c'est une motivation pour toi
aussi et moi personnellement quand je
suis des gens qui réussit dans la ville
je me dis ah pourquoi je l'aurais sur
mon téléphone pourquoi je vais je ne
vais rien faire de préférence je
poursuis mère et moi ça me motive de
voir des gens qui réussissent ça me
motive bon ça dépend de chaque personne
quand je suis des personnes qui qui
alimentent trop la culture du vide c'est
parfois ça fait du bien de regarder des
vidéos qui n'ont rien apporté à ta
valeur
et à son développement personnel
mais c'est quand même bien et très
important de suivre des gens qui vont se
rajouter quelque chose et en moins le
temps que tu passes sur les réseaux mais
même si je les accueille